okay so the Trump administration has
officially banned bump stocks for
firearms am I now ready to give Donald
Trump credit for doing something good on
guns sure he banned bump stocks and bump
stocks should be banned and that's
perfectly fine the problem is that bump
stocks are a really safe thing to ban
politically because you can do it
without actually doing a damn thing
about the gun violence problem in this
country bump stocks are aftermarket
modifications to guns which allow non
automatic guns to fire in rapid
succession to make them function more
like automatic weapons which would be
banned if you were to buy them in that
sort of mode from the manufacturer in
other words a lot they start to
approximate firearms that you can't
legally buy so the banning of bump
stocks is correct but it's also bogus as
a major gun safety victory for a couple
different reasons number one again these
are aftermarket parts that are often not
even made by gun manufacturers so if
your Trump you can really safely do this
without angering the NRA which actually
has said I believe at certain points
that they wouldn't be opposed to the
banning of bump stocks you can do it
without angering the clients of the NRA
which are gun manufacturers since they
mostly aren't making bump stocks they
are aftermarket third party
parts and the banning of bump stocks
might even generate more sales for the
NRA zku clients the gun manufacturers
since people will not be able to modify
their guns in certain ways they might
just go out and get something that is a
little higher-end or more interesting to
them from the manufacturer to begin with
so it's actually not that big of a deal
that the NRA was okay with banning bump
stocks and that Donald Trump has done
this secondly and very importantly
bumped stocks are almost never a factor
in shootings yes the Las Vegas gunman
used bump stocks to modify the weapons
he used in killing those 58
people in that horrible nightmarish
tragedy that took place in Las Vegas
Nevada but usually bump stocks aren't
used in these shootings and additionally
the law the regulation from Trump may
not even hold for two different reasons
number one bump stocks are accessories
and so there would be there is a legal
argument to make that the federal
government cannot regulate them because
they're not firearms they are
accessories so that's one reason why
Trump's regulation may be thrown out
secondly there's a due process issue
that some legal experts are pointing to
which is that Donald Trump is saying
that people will have 90 days to turn in
or destroy their bump stocks legal
experts are concerned that that may get
the regulation thrown out because it
lacks all due process period so again
when we take a step back do I agree with
banning bump stocks Pat yes I do but
it's insignificant to the gun
manufacturers it's almost non-existent
as a factor in mass shootings and there
are two different bases on which it
might be struck down by courts but are
we to believe that Donald Trump is
taking gun safety really seriously as a
result of this yeah at that being said I
am happy that they're doing it but it
just took way too long like the Las
Vegas shooting was over a year ago at
this point and I think that shows me
that they were trying to weigh what the
political repercussions would be how the
NRA would respond to it how their voters
would respond to it and it's coming
across as too little too late I hope it
does prevent future mass shootings and I
think it will but I'd like to see a lot
more I'm not trying to rain on anybody's
parade I agree with the decision it's
just a very safe easy and obvious
decision let's look at passing universal
background checks for every single gun
transaction regardless of where it takes
place that now is something that the
people of the United States are mostly
in agreement with
but we've not been able as I spoke about
yesterday with dr. Joseph saccharin
we've not been able to get that past and
made into law so you know again things
aren't black and white I can say this is
the right decision while also saying it
is not a decision that is politically
risky not a decision that is legally
even completely clear that is going to
stand and not a decision that will have
a significant impact on mass shootings
on the basis of our understanding of how
mass shootings work in the United States
if I am being not favorable enough let
me know but I'm telling you it's the
right decision I'm just saying cheering
too much about this as making Trump a
doer on the topic of gun safety
regulation seems to go completely
contradictory to the facts make sure
you're following me on Twitter at de
Pakman followed the show on Twitter at
David Pakman show fantastic Friday show
for you today one of the day's sponsors
is privacy comm slash Pakman which is a
free service that I myself use really
useful in many different ways takes just
a few seconds to link your debit card to
privacy comm then you can create virtual
credit cards that are linked directly to
your bank account and you use those
virtual credit card numbers to buy
things online which protects your actual
debit card so that it's not spread all
over the internet and one of the best
things about it is how their mobile app
and browser extensions for Chrome and
Firefox make it really easy to use let's
say for example that I'm signing up for
a david pakman show membership in the
credit card number field I already see
the privacy comm icon I just click it
choose which of my virtual credit cards
I want to use and the credit card number
expiration date and security code are
automatically entered I can put in any
zip code I want and I'm done and if you
try to use my credit card number that
you just saw on the screen it doesn't
matter because I've already deleted that
virtual card and that's the beauty of
privacy comm there are a ton of
advantages to using a
free service like this for example you
can sign up for as many free trials as
you want then just delete the virtual
credit card you used and never worry
about getting charged for it it protects
you from getting hacked it protects you
when companies are hacked which happens
all the time it is all completely free
all you have to do is click the link
under this video to get started and for
a limited time they're giving everyone
in our audience $5 towards your first
purchase when you sign up using that
link